hey guys it is the 24th of November
today my name is just ambitious bunny
guys are giving us a glimpse of the
first piece of star wars battlefront DLC
and introduce a brand new 40 plan though
the battle of jakku we'll introduce a
map as well as the brand new mode called
turning point in turning point rebels
must locate and attack three ariel bases
times have emphasized that captured
bases will become increasingly more
challenging but that once rebels
initiate takeover of a base it cannot be
reclaimed lead level designer dennis
brown avail explains let's say there are
only twenty five percent left of the
claim process and the Empire has managed
to drive away the rebels this means that
the Empire have to choose between
defending this vulnerable point or
another part of the map there won't be
any Sal fight is involved it since most
of the action is infantry focused but
you'll be able to hop in an airspeeder
or 80s to the battle of jakku lands as
free DLC on December one if you
pre-ordered battlefront and december
eight for everyone else since we're
talking me mode GTA online is introduced
a new mode that is essentially football
with cars so you don't confuse it with
rocket League here's the lowdown this
new adversary mode is called running
back and is inspired by american
football not the stock account rockstar
have said the mode course with two teams
of four to eight players to attempt to
stop the runner from getting his or her
benefactor panto mini card to the far
end of a highway imagine a lot of
crashing into the other team to ensure
that doesn't happen running back can be
played at renton canyon bridge at La
Mesa bridge and it thank you don't tamil
the mode is only coming to pc ps4 and
xbox one so those of you on last general
just need to invent your own car
slashing
finally a nice jalwa battlefront
graphics PC mod has made the game look
insanely realistic Colonel Martin
Bergman who was also responsible for an
incredible graphic enhancing mod for GTA
has released various images of his toddy
handsome odds for battlefront it uses a
variety of tools to affect the
post-processing of the game and as
effects like ambient occlusion and depth
of field okay currently the mod is still
a work in progress and isn't available
to the public but given his previous
work and the glimpses were getting so
far this is definitely one to look
forward to for battle fronts and let me
know down in the comments if you're keen
to play the new modes in star wars
battlefront and GTA online you can add
the games but we've got stories on the
rainbow 6 siege beta and an epic new
Witcher 3 trailer that is everything I
have you today but be sure to pop by
same time tomorrow for a bunch more news